à ma droite se trouve le chef de file de la série Bounty Law
et Jack Cahill lui-même Rick Dalton et
à ma gauche se trouve Rick Stunt double cliff
stand alors Rick explique au public
exactement ce que c'est un cascadeur double
les acteurs sont-ils tenus de faire beaucoup de
trucs dangereux falaise ici  est destiné à
aider à porter la charge, c'est que la façon dont vous
décrivez votre travail falaise qui porte
sa charge et un pré de pomme d'hôtel un
renversement de fiction pop de film vacant à un
brutal particulièrement pasajeros ensoleillé plus
bientôt un saloon via CTV secondes
trajectoire d'arôme un campus Jones palace  un ciné cinéma
disent les fans de Sébastien a car
les détracteurs de très longtemps aprés
basterds peu glorieux K value est il un
pré-sélecteur Cristo voûte en l'état
un mamelon un tourisme pour la concurrence je peux
au quantifier l'actualité je suis à Hollywood
LM inévitable ou  pas un festival mesdames
et messieurs Quentin Tarantino l'eau comme
on dit en français il était une fois à
Hollywood l'heure est 1969 et je crois que
vous êtes arrivé à LA au milieu des années soixante
1965 Ryan je me demandais si cet
étrange mélange de flower power et de violence
télé  et le nouvel Hollywood était le décor de
ton enfance ouais je ne pense pas que j'ai
vraiment compris la violence ou quelque chose
comme ça tu sais mais au moment où tu
arrives à avoir environ six ans c'est quand
tu commences vraiment à avoir une conscience
de ce qui se passe  autour de vous, vous
savez que vous commencez à avoir des émissions de télévision que vous
aimez que vous voulez regarder et commencer à
aller au cinéma et tout et non j'étais
j'étais très conscient de toute la
culture hippie oui c'était ce qui se passait je
n'étais pas au courant  la culture Manson mais je
m'inquiétais de la culture hippie
parce que vous savez que des amis auraient mes
parents, que mes amis feraient des fêtes et
qu'ils mettraient la
bande originale de Woodstock, vous ne pouviez pas allumer la
télévision sans voir des hippies, vous
voyiez des hippies marcher dans la
rue.  connais la plupart des baby-sitters
comment diriez-vous un jour que true
romance était l'un de vos films les plus
autobiographiques et je
me demandais pourquoi regarder il était une fois
si ce n'était pas maintenant ouais eh bien non c'est
bien true romance est plus ou  moins
à propos de moi d'accord, mais c'était vous savez que
cela ressemble plus à un coran d'Alphonse roma
d'accord où c'est comme si c'était un
morceau de mémoire alors je retourne dans mon moi de six ans
pour me souvenir de ce que tout était
et pour moi Quentin ceci  est probablement
le plus mélancolique de tous vos
films ressentez-vous une sorte de nostalgie
pour cette époque de la fin des années 60
eh bien je pense que je pense que c'est en ligue
avec Jackie Brown quand il s'agit de ça
je pense que je pense qu'ils  ont
beaucoup de qualités et les mêmes et les deux se
déroulent dans un
certain quartier de Los Angeles que je connaissais
bien et j'essayais de le recréer comment l'avez-
vous créé quel traitement avez-
vous choisi pour créer cette atmosphère
justement bien  vous savez, je pense que vous savez que
nous sommes dans une situation intéressante, je pense que nous
pourrions être la dernière production de cette
taille à pouvoir aller dans une ville animée
comme Los Angeles et inverser l'
horloge comme nous l'avons fait au moins pas
seulement  le faire avec CGI et mettre
des écrans verts partout, non, nous avons construit des choses
et l'une des raisons pour lesquelles je pense que nous
pourrions être bien dans les derniers est que
ce sera rare pour quelqu'un qui veut
dépenser cet argent pour faire ça et être
capable d'avoir la situation qu'ils peuvent
faire, mais encore une fois, la ville
change si rapidement que c'était comme si nous
faisions ce film quand nous l'avons fait,
nous n'aurions peut-être pas pu le faire
comme nous l'avons fait un an plus tard  c'était comme si
nous étions comme si nous courions pour le faire
sur un pont en feu et nous étions juste
comme nous le faisions mais le pont
brûle littéralement derrière nous aimez-vous toujours
Hollywood entre vous et moi
autant que vous l'avez fait ouais  Je suppose que oui euh-huh
absolument mais je tu sais il y a je veux dire
il y a Hollywood l'industrie et il
y a Hollywood la ville ayons la
ville d'Hollywood je
parle de l'industrie bien sur ouais bien ouais
euh bien j'aime tous mes
amis là-dedans  et j'ai une bonne
situation alors ouais qu'est-ce qu'il ne faut pas aimer il était
une fois à Hollywood bien sûr
ça ressemble au début d'un conte de
quel genre de conte ou même de conte de fées
parlez-vous ouais je
pense vraiment qu'il y a un aspect fataliste  à cela,
je veux dire, vous savez à cet égard, je veux dire
euh,
je pense que vous savez que c'est probablement mon
plus si j'allais qu'ils vont
échanger l'attribution d'un autre réalisateur à il était
une fois à Hollywood, je pense que c'est
probablement mon plus Claude Lelouch oh
vraiment
comme un film d'accord parce que ses films
ont ça comme s'il avait le placage de
réalisme mais il y a toujours ce
conte de fées presque romantique à quel film de
coluche pensez-vous je
pense à tous ceux que j'ai jamais vu
juste le film de Lelouch bien là  il
y a toujours ce genre d'aspect de fable
et puis toujours ce genre de
concept comme vous savez que le
sous-texte de tous ses films est les films que
j'aime les films et que j'aime et vous savez
parce que les gens ne m'associent pas à ça
Est-ce que de cette façon, je ne pense pas qu'ils aient vu le
voir, mais si je devais prendre si je
devais sortir tous ces trucs de radio Cage J
et jouer de la musique Francis Francis
tout au long, vous le verriez
immédiatement et clewd Lelouch arrive
être un grand réalisateur d'acteurs et il
faut parler de ses acteurs et
surtout de ce duo
Leonardo DiCaprio Brad Pitt ensemble
pourquoi les avez vous choisis dans quoi qu'est ce qu'ils
représentent pour vous à
Hollywood aujourd'hui eh bien ils vous le savez
avant tout  ce sont tous les deux des
acteurs vraiment formidables et et qui se sont
avérés être deux des plus grandes stars
de vous savez notre génération en fait dans les
deux cas j'ai travaillé avec les deux
donc nous nous aimons bien et nous et moi sommes
assez chanceux  qu'ils répondent à mon
matériel, mais vous devez vous rappeler qu'il
est important que ces deux personnages
cliff et Rick aient besoin d'aller ensemble,
vous savez, car l'un est un acteur et l'
autre est un cascadeur, vous savez que
Harrison Ford a bien un cascadeur  il
ressemble un peu à ça, vous savez et ils
n'ont même pas besoin de ressembler à la personne,
mais vous devez suggérer à la personne que vous
devez avoir à peu près la même taille, vous devez
pouvoir porter les mêmes vêtements qu'ils
portent en doublant  pour eux et vous
savez peut-être que vos cheveux sont un peu
différents mais vous portez une perruque et de temps en temps
vous devriez être les deux gars qui se
ressemblent donc quelque chose donc ils devaient
avoir un et vous savez une coque extérieure qui
allait bien ensemble je pense  c'est
fascinant de t'entendre parler d'
actrice parce que tu ne le fais pas tout le temps et
mais tu dis que ce sont des
acteurs formidables ce qui fait un bon acteur pour toi
Quinton mm-hmm en fait je suppose que j'aime le
personnage j'aime les acteurs qui  faire du
travail de personnage qui aime vraiment investir dans
le personnage qui est ce gars et
découvrir et peut-être qu'ils n'ont pas
toutes les réponses tout de suite mais
ils vont juste continuer à explorer qui
est cette personne qui est cette personne vous
connaissez l'histoire  est important au début mais
maintenant ils n'ont pas à penser à l'
histoire maintenant ils se soucient juste de qui
c'est et laissez-moi réfléchir à l'histoire mais
ensuite l'autre chose que vous pour moi
fait un très bon acteur est qu'ils connaissent
le dialogue  est-ce que tu les aides beaucoup tu leur
parles beaucoup ouais oh ouais je peux
leur parler tu sais certains acteurs veulent
ça plus certains acteurs veulent ça moins mais
je connais très bien les personnages je sais
exactement qui ils sont et même je vais  écrire
écrire des trucs et c'est mon travail de juger
à quel point un acteur veut savoir ouais d'
accord, vous savez, si cela n'implique pas l'
histoire, ils peuvent proposer
autre chose que moi, il y a cette
scène Quentin où un  petite fille
donne à Leo une leçon de théâtre et l'
Actors Studio que pensez-vous de
cette école de théâtre les acteurs pour vous
diriez-vous que c'était une bonne chose pour le
cinéma pour Hollywood l'histoire du film
euh oh tu veux dire l'Actors Studio en
général ouais  pas avec la méthode des petites filles
oh ouais eh bien elle ne vient pas vraiment
de l'Actors Studio, elle
vient plus de plus de là était un
directeur de théâtre nommé Harold Clurman
d'accord, il a dirigé un John Barrymore
et Hamlet à Broadway et il a écrit un
livre magnifique elle est  en quelque sorte venant un
peu plus de la théorie de Harold Clurman
un peu sur un rôle sur la vérité
sur la fiction aussi
je dois vous poser cette question dans
Inglourious Basterds vous avez changé l'
histoire pendant la Seconde Guerre mondiale et il semble que
la fiction ait un tel  partie importante de
votre travail dans le monde d'aujourd'hui
qu'aimeriez-vous changer avec la magie de la
fiction oh wow
en fait nous voulons changer beaucoup de
choses je changerais beaucoup de choses d'accord euh
d'abord si je pouvais claquer des doigts
et rien de tout  ces appareils photo numériques
existaient et vous tourniez ici en 16
millimètres et tous les films du Khan
Film Festival jouaient en 35
millimètres ou 16 millimètres, ce
serait formidable si je pouvais claquer du doigt une
seconde fois et tous les téléphones portables
du monde étaient  non inventé je ferais ça
tu sais ça pourrait lelouch que tu as
mentionné fermer une partie de son nouveau film avec
un iPhone je pense qu'il a tourné l'autre
aussi avec lequel j'ai beaucoup aimé
encore une fois c'est vrai que tu as tourné ce
film ce nouveau film avec notre
film génétique combien de temps pensez-vous qu'il sera
possible de faire ça Quinton je pense que le
codex en assez bon état je pense que nous sommes je pense que
nous y étions était c'était risqué
là-bas pendant un petit moment mais je pense que moi
et Christopher Nolan et moi  pense que nous nous
et le studio avons pris un engagement je
pense que nous allons bien mais que perdrions-nous
si vous perdiez la texture du film
à l'avenir qui pourrait être dans Matt ou
vous me perdez c'est sûr vous vous l'avez dit
plusieurs fois ça  inglourious
basterds n'était pas totalement terminé quand
c'était une audience peut quand a été montré en
boîte la version de once upon tyne
hollywood que nous avons vu ici est-ce celui
qui sera là sortira en
salles mais pour la plupart je veux dire
ce n'est pas  je vais euh j'aurai environ une
semaine et demie je pourrais je pourrais jouer
un peu avec ça ouais ça ne va pas
être plus court je pourrais ajouter un petit
quelque chose ou quelque chose tu sais
idée de ce que tu vas ajouter c'est tout
pensées c'est toutes les pensées c'est toutes les
pensées c'est comme si j'aurais un
peu de temps
mais l'idée est que je voulais en quelque sorte y aller je
voulais venir venir avec un film plus serré
que la normale je voulais vous
savez si quelque chose que je voulais  pour être trop sûr de ce que cela
signifie plus serré juste plus serré
par opposition à plus lâche et faites tout le
montage je veux dire que vous êtes ici tout le temps
et vous faites tout et vous contrôlez
tout oh ouais je suis dans la
salle de montage plus jamais je  signifie que mon éditeur fait
les coupes physiques mais ouais nous sommes assis
juste à côté l'un de l'autre sentez-vous que
vous contrôlez très bien en tant que réalisateur ou
pas dans le montage dans le puits c'est vous
savez que c'est mon film bien sûr et il est
important de considérer je veux dire votre  tu
es ton film et le fait que tu fasses
tout Quentin bien ouais eh bien ouais
c'est comme si la dernière ébauche du script
était le premier montage du film Wow et
le dernier montage du film était l'
ébauche finale du script
Quincy ce qui fait  vous êtes le plus
fier de ce film en particulier et
bien j'avais un j'avais un très très bon
film dans ma tête vous savez que je me suis
promené avec ce film dans ma tête pendant
quelques années et je sens que j'ai réalisé le
film que j'ai vu dans  ma tête donc je suis
assez content de ça donc un bon film
pour vous est le film que le réalisateur
avait en tête
ouais et a réussi à faire était-ce le cas
pour tous vos films eh bien ouais je suppose que c'est
le cas pour tous mes pouces mais  celui-ci
je suppose que c'était peut-être un vous savez que c'était l'un
des c'était l'un des plus difficiles
vous avez dit un jour que vous ne tourneriez
que dix longs métrages celui-ci est le
neuvième c'est vrai oui avez-vous en
tête le prochain  un déjà
non qui fait partie du plaisir en ce
moment est que je n'ai aucune idée et comment ça
vient une idée ça vient juste un jour non
c'est juste Wyatt mais quelque chose quelque chose
va arriver mais c'est comme d'habitude c'est
comme un tu sais que je vais  être sur ce film
pendant environ un an, puis j'ai généralement
environ un an de congé et quelque part et que
vers la fin de cette année,
quelque chose se présentera mais la
dernière façon ça doit être une bonne idée non oh ouais ouais
non je '  Je ne suis pas pressé, tu
sais,
mais j'ai toujours dit dix ou j'ai eu 60 ans, donc selon la
première éventualité, attendras-tu
jusqu'à ce que tu aies 60 ans - non non, je dis juste non
si j'ai 60 ans, alors pas dix, tu sais bien
quel est le dernier  on sera sur oh non je n'en
ai absolument aucune idée
merci beaucoup pour cette interview mon
plaisir
c'est une belle interview Merci Quentin
merci pour cette interview vote - il était une
fois dans l'épopée hollywoodienne Leonardo
DiCaprio Brad Pitt naginata meeting all
competition festival  a commencé est une pomme de terre
Obama a jus Google sueur est une terrible
auto-évaluation de la portion de bétail merci
infiniment Eridani con toda la casa na
CA - Z - Travis Philly pour traiter la
rue qui était le meilleur jeu d'acteur que j'ai
jamais vu de toute ma vie merci  toi
[Musique]
toi